spent 24 hours in Melbourne it's very
clear so many of you are trying to take
the next step in your careers but you
just don't know how how do you Chunk Up
here's a take on that
I think trade attention and build
businesses
just landed in Melbourne off to the
hotel going to
shower run right downstairs meet a gift
go from be friends basically we've got
the next 14 hours program straight I
made a crucial mistake in the flight it
was 25 hour flight I woke up eight hours
ago worked the whole way this is going
to be a rough one see how the energy
holds up a little groggy right now
25 26 hours of travel it's kind of rough
she like I like what I'm seeing now we
yeah
uh this this this one I really want do
you want to win them off with me yes
probably even
though I don't think I can win oh that's
why you have to be left-sided yeah I've
streamed my pack in Chicago and like
it's killing me and left side it was
funny Mike's do you think I can beat you
in arm wrestling
I don't see it oh it's so big look at
this it's not
fully documented
yeah there's no chance
[Music]
you know we're gonna edit it with just
the place where I won yesterday thanks
guys enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
all right going into a client meeting so
you'll be not filming this yeah tell him
don't play when y'all got gang with me
this one trade with me I've been a blame
you and tape for the sake of it heart
due to race on stage I gotta hear him to
the Great Lakes City slide in the grab
like a wave full of tank in it I'll be
clearing space for me I've been feeling
great
literally if it's one person I'll just
go hard yeah like Rick what's really
wild about it is like I generally like
of course I'd be like hey what went
wrong but I wouldn't be like oh I suck
or this sucks I'd be like Rick you gotta
[__] it you know like I can get really
hyped I just want the glory friend see
that expression on your face is so bad
to me why so serious
[Music]
oh yeah
how do you prepare in that situation you
mean like this piece of cake just never
ever ever talk about something I'll see
you later take care of yourself
hey hello hello
thank you for coming
yeah of course thank you brother it's
good to be back honestly I'm looking to
provide as much value in this setting as
possible and thrilled to answer any
question that anybody might have
yeah
I struggle a lot with like
I guess chunking up the things that I
want to do because like I'll have a
product I want to do I'll have something
I want to write I like this I want to do
yeah like how do you Chunk Up the things
that you do a couple things work for me
one I'm not scared to lose so I think a
lot of times a lot of people don't do a
lot of things because they can't take
the L when you're doing 31 things like
seven are gonna fail quickly and I'm
just okay with that and I think that's
one thing to think about how old are you
um 26 yeah I mean there's just some
there's a level of practice to it
because I like juggling 30 balls because
I'm okay with seven of them breaking
most people are like petrified for a
ball to drop pleasure I'll see you out
there hi nice to meet you pleasure
[Music]
so you're gonna fireside chat me and
then we're gonna do q a
together
as as money mindset have been an issue
at all or as it seemed like a bright
price of your byproduct money's good and
all like I understand what it is it's
just the problem is I just know way too
many people with money that are
miserable and this is where luck comes
in for sure I love business we're living
in an era where people have put
entrepreneurship on a pedestal and a lot
of people are forcing themselves to be
on others when they're not
self-awareness is what leads to
happiness not everybody should be an
entrepreneur it takes a real stomach to
be honestly everything's on you people
like what's your morning routine I'm
like I wake up and look at my phone to
make sure the world's not on fire
because my Singapore office is open and
Australia is like it's constant anxiety
you gotta like it for it not to be
anxiety but if you don't like it and you
were not built for it it [__] is the
worst and I watch entrepreneurship eat
up people every day I think we should go
to the audience now if you have a
question for Gary we're gonna ask you to
do is line up on one of these
microphones I highly recommend you get
your ass in line let's get going
hi
Gary my name is Nick hello I was part of
eruption five I was the added to for 26
years and overcame that addiction two
and a half years clean now
So I placed my journey on social media I
feel I'm making an impact I'm still
trying to get a [__] handle on life
and it's a journey I'm learning we all
are yeah yeah like I'm impacting people
I'm starting to be consistent in the gym
and I'm getting [__] messages I'm
consistently too this is amazing and and
the thing is I'm unemployed I'm just
wondering do you have any advice of how
I can monetize what I'm doing or I mean
do you want to get a job yeah but but
that's this is me like I love I love
posting my journey but I'm asking you a
really practical question because I want
you to win monetizing is very
challenging let me explain you've got to
either get brand deals you've got to
either be a big enough Creator where
you're getting meaningful money from the
revenue share of the platforms which you
have to be at a very high level for that
you have to create a product to sell you
could create a course or charge your
audience I think that changes the entire
Dynamic of it monetizing is challenging
the reason I'm asking is I think the
same tenacity you're attacking this with
applying to 10 or 15 jobs a with good
copy and good videos is something you
also have to give a thought to yeah
because I think the stability of having
the job nine to five and then do content
afterwards might take the anxiety off
because when you're unemployed it's on
your mind yeah 100 and then you may you
might actually be sitting on some it's
very important I want everybody to hear
this you might be sitting on something
very powerful but you have to keep doing
it for another three years before it
goes to where you want it to but if
you're so anxious to turn it into money
you're going to lose your audience
because they're going to feel it and all
you needed to do was get a nine to five
okay yeah
because I put on the mileage I'll finish
but I'm down for the challenge step off
the scene just to find me a balance
thank you Mama I love you thank you
[Applause]
that was like more like a
therapy session yeah yeah
I like the kind of mellow kind of like
it was like a family conversation
the job up there and in the morning
didn't feel was tired of being single so
I went and got a real
such a pleasure you don't want to go in
through these lines of 100 people and
taking these quick selfies you know I'm
empathetic that the uh the event is
normally trying to get through everybody
they're probably being empathetic to me
and want to get me home it's a long day
but the reality is is like having that
microsecond seeing how people are doing
making sure I connect with them you know
is very important to me
[Music]
walking into a client dinner at eight to
ten clients so really double dipping
here between the you know speaking tour
and vaynermedia Business Development
anytime you can get two for the price of
one it's always good so we're gonna go
in here I'm gonna meet with some Vayner
Sports past people right after this of
course have a wonderful evening so we'll
see them we'll see you in Sydney
a lot of things I think about is doing
things when it's hard from New York to
San Francisco San Francisco to Melbourne
we're in the air for 24 hours we land we
shower we go right at it you saw
everything we're doing like [__]
meetings and the meetings and the
meetings and Keynotes and meanings and
lines now I'm sitting with two gentlemen
who own Vayner Sports passes who AJ
calls me you know three weeks ago and
says hey there's a couple of holders of
Vayner Sports bass they live in
Australia I'd love for you to meet them
and they're in Melbourne well my
Melbourne name was super duper packed
and like as you can imagine after 14
hours sitting in the lobby of the hotel
at midnight and chopping it up with
these guys for an hour that is
challenging but the reality is so many
of you that are watching here you want
the finished product well these are the
details like are you willing to do
something for your community are you
willing to sit here and bring value I
sat there for an hour and answered all
the business questions and I was locked
in just doing it's not enough you got to
do it right meaning I wouldn't do it if
I was going to mail it in because I'm
going to leave a bad impression and
that's a waste of you know energy on
both sides and so you know this is just
a clip to wrap up the day the reality is
I'm [__] exhausted at this point and
the question is if you want it like
they're going to be moments where you're
gonna go harder and stronger and deeper
than than you know maybe you even want
to sometimes you got to dig a little bit
deeper especially and this is the key
here especially for all of you that are
talking that [__]
all right
foreign